welcome to hannity
americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 30.
it is officially day 30 americans held
hostage they were abandoned by joe biden
behind enemy lines tonight there are
many americans still trapped behind
enemy lines hostage to the whims of the
taliban the terrorists we still cannot
get an exact number which in and of
itself is a disgrace
and likely hundreds of americans and
more when you start including their
family members our fellow citizens
hopelessly trapped in afghanistan along
with thousands of green card holders
thousands more with special immigration
visas and our afghan allies yeah they
now will be sentenced to death one after
another it's already begun they're all
now at the mercy of the taliban
according to the biden administration
they're very business-like and very
professional and of course nothing could
be further from the true
truth these are evil murdering
terrorists joe who now control the fate
of scores of americans and our allies
for 20 years that we made a promise to
we get him out of this moment ever came
you abandoned them as we speak taliban
death squads are now going door to door
they're hunting their political enemies
when anyone with any ties to america or
the west and according to the times of
london at least four american trained
anti-terrorism agents they were tortured
they were murdered by these death squads
one victim had all of his fingernails
pulled out before they shot him in the
head how's that for professional and
business like joe and tony blinken and
jen saki now this updated image posted
to social media about a week ago
obtained by the washington examiner now
we have not verified it but it shows the
taliban beheading of an afghan soldier
washington examiner they have the video
we have this picture very professional
and business-like right joe no other
videos not yet verified by fox show
taliban terrorists now we do have videos
of them whipping and beating women now
all over the country this is happening
daily now and with regularity under
taliban rule it is illegal for women of
protest it is illegal for women to hold
certain jobs it is illegal for women to
show any of their face in public women
are now segregated in schools and there
are reports of young girls ripped away
from their moms and dads and forced to
marry taliban fighters and become sex
slaves or become sex slaves there are
travel restrictions on women clothing
restrictions schooling work restrictions
breaking any rule that results in
whippings and beatings or death and just
listen to this gut-wrenching video as
evidence
[Music]
[Applause]
beating a woman who's screaming
professional and business-like
joe you're watching clearly afghanistan
is once again hell on earth for all
women and others a paradise for the
world's most brutal terrorists according
to several top experts including obama's
own secretary of defense and former cia
director leon panetta this country is
now a safe haven for al qaeda isis isis
k and other terror groups and as for the
over horizon anti-terror strategy that
joe biden is now bragging about he's
also bragging about having leveraged
that he has none
it's not going so well look at this
investigation from the washington post
and the new york times wow even a blind
squirrel gets the acorn right
a recent drone strike you know the one
they they bragged about but they
wouldn't tell us who actually got hit
the one they said targeted an imminent
isis threat armed with explosives yeah
the washington post in the new york
times they're now saying that the they
killed an unarmed human rights worker
and seven children
joe you did that americans and our
allies left behind enemy lines 13
american soldiers murdered and now we're
taking aid workers and young children
and joe killed them imagine if it was
donald trump and a terrorist safe haven
in afghanistan 20 years after 9 11.
biden's spineless impotent actions
surrounding the withdrawal have been so
bad that joe is now getting booed pretty
much everywhere he goes including this
weekend at the 911 memorial
weak feeble cognitive mess notice that
joe is walking in with bill clinton and
barack obama in order to look more
credible less weak and pathetic as he
really is but it really doesn't matter
does it because everyone on earth all of
our enemies out all of our allies
everyone knows very few people have the
courage to just say it joe biden is
completely and totally inept and out of
it they know his clueless secretary of
state isn't much better yet tony blinken
today didn't even have the courtesy of
going before congress walking two blocks
announced that he expects the terrorists
and the taliban the professional and
business-like taliban to uphold their
commitments on counter-terrorism and
respect the basic rights of women and
girls just like last week he was
lecturing then on wokeness and
inclusivity
how dumb is this man take a look we
expect the taliban to ensure freedom of
travel
to make good on his commitments on
counterterrorism
to uphold the basic rights of the afghan
people including women girls and
minorities
to name a broadly representative
permanent government to force reprisals
where's mike pompeo when we need him we
now have a secretary of state so totally
completely utterly clueless
kind of makes neville chamberlain look
like
patton in comparison tony blinken is
really that dumb and a complete fool no
clue about the real world no clue or
understanding at all about the enemy
that is the taliban they are our enemy
they are terrorists how dumb are you how
is it possible for some
one person to be that stupid he expects
terrorists to uphold their
anti-terrorism commitments lectures them
on wokeness inclusiveness expects the
sharia loving taliban to protect the
rights of women and girls you're not
watching the videos tony you know you're
not seeing any of the beatings we're
showing almost nightly tony and today
blinken wasn't given the benefit of the
doubt uh to the top he was actually
giving the benefit of the doubt to the
taliban as he was busy trashing donald
trump the same donald trump who before
they had any negotiation said i will
obliterate you if you don't follow every
dotted eye cross t comma and period
and he would have done it take a look
how meticulous was the planning for the
trump administration declared may 1st
withdrawal
well thank you congressman uh we uh we
inherited a deadline we did not inherit
a plan
so
nope
no plan at all
it's amazing that it wasn't much much
worse
you also inherited secure borders energy
independence and a good economy that was
bouncing back and you raised covert
cases by 300 percent compared to last
year uh you had no problem ruining the
good policies of donald trump but now
it's convenient you want to blame trump
for the fact that you didn't obliterate
them the way trump would have trump's
deadline was in may that's before the
taliban fighting season that's the opium
season the biden administration blew
right through the deadline blinken was
lying as the world watched the taliban
on the move they did nothing when they
had full safety and security at kabul
they could have extracted every american
every afghan ally and even the billions
of dollars of military equipment now
donald trump's plan the one that he had
in place we were going to keep program
air base in perpetuity and we were going
to hold the taliban accountable by force
if they stepped one inch out of where
they were allowed to step he would have
bombed the living adam schiff of them
anyway if they harmed any american not a
single american died in 18 months the
last year of trump's presidency not one
anthony blinken is living in an
alternate reality if he had any honor at
all he doesn't he would resign
immediately should be fired impeached
but guess what he doesn't have honor or
decency and he's not bright in fact he
didn't even show up to his hearing at
capitol hill today instead he appeared
on a webcam from his office like three
blocks away take a look
mr blinken assuming it's not classified
can you tell us where you are today
uh yes i'm uh at the state department
couldn't couldn't be bothered to come
down here and see congress all right
that's great how many afghan citizens
came to the united states that had not
met the qualifications for special
immigrant visa
we're in the process
how many did you bring you were just at
dulles how many did you bring we have we
will have by the end of the month we
will have brought a total of
approximately 60 000 that have not met
the sib process
some of those will be some of those will
have been through the siv process our
afghan refugees required to be
vaccinated for coveted before coming to
the united states of america
uh they are vaccinated in the united
states before they are before they are
resettled
they didn't vet them they didn't have
culvert protocols they only exist for
american citizens do you hear that we
left thousands of green card holders
sivs american citizens behind enemy
lines in afghanistan but somehow
evacuated tens of thousands of people
other people without any appropriate
paperwork and no vetting and according
to congressman tom tiffany wisconsin
many of these potentially unvetted
individuals they're allowed to leave a
wisconsin military base completely
unsupervised and travel as they please
unvetted great work tony great job
mission accomplished job joe way to go
by the way it's monday joe in case
nobody reminded you or gave you a card
mark my words this crisis will have
lasting consequences for our country one
of the biggest foreign policy debacles
in the history of this great republic at
one point during the hearing the line of
questioning took a pretty unexpected
turn blinking was left totally
completely speechless which actually was
maybe the only moment it made sense take
a look
how long was your recent interview with
the fbi and was it a deposition
i'm sorry i don't know what you're
referring are you saying that you have
not had a recent interview with the fbi
since becoming secretary of state
i'm
i
i'm not sure what you're referring to
did the state department turn over
documents to the fbi related to hunter
biden barisma and or the blue state
strategies corporation
uh you'll
have to uh so you have no knowledge of
this you have had no you don't you are
you saying you have not had an interview
fbi for me to comment uh in a public
would
with
the
forum on any uh legal proceedings that
the department
oh
muhammad ahmed ahamad you want to plead
the fifth tony now based on blinkens
weird answers i'd guess that he has been
interviewed by the fbi just to guess
about hunter and biden's family's
illicit international money-making
scheme you know the syndicate very
serious if the president of the united
states is in any way compromised you the
american people i think deserve to know
that hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else